yes I am Conan O'Brien coming to you
from my home in Los Angeles where I'm
under quarantine like so many of us are
and tonight I'm going to wear glasses
because I'm told glasses make me looks
mad
real smart check this out hey America
asked me how I did in the fight
Conan how'd you do in the fight pretty
good I guess I'm losing my mind
cuz I think that's actually pretty good
comedy
[Laughter]
wow man yeah this thing's doing a number
on all of us guess what this is a
confession
I slept till noon today yeah to be fair
to me though I went to bed at 8:00 p.m.
so you know I needed my beauty rest
clearly it's all falling apart it's
crazy right now this is a true story
scientists are saying they think the
corona virus came to New York through
Europe they think it came from Europe
yeah scientists say they know that it
came from Europe because they've studied
its genetic structure and also it's a
terrible tipper yeah yeah they also saw
it in in Central Park it's on the corner
of eros wearing Birkenstocks with socks
it had a fanny pack
it was speaking German look if you've
got complaints about any of these jokes
seriously you can email me you can write
me a letter and I'll ignore it because
what do you want seriously what do you
want fantastic show tonight
excellent show a good friend Joel McHale
is on the program tonight we're gonna
have a good time with him but first I
didn't want to mention something so many
people are shining a light on the
businesses that have stayed open
throughout this crisis the essential
businesses the essential services that
different states have said must continue
here's kind of a controversial one
Florida decided a while ago that
wrestling was an essential service yes
essential and so it is continued the WWE
has continued throughout this crisis and
we thought
one should tip their cap to the good
folks of a WWE take a look
day after day we're watching heroes risk
their health and safety to keep the rest
of us going strong doctors nurses
grocery workers delivery people and
professional wrestlers those selfless
gladiators who elbow smash cross chop
and clothesline each other day after day
for our amusement
frontline heroes like mojo Rowley Roman
reigns
Natalya and Sasha banks choking each
other out so the rest of us can breathe
a little easier thank you for your
service WWE and thank you for once again
you've out floored at yourself